all right guys
bang bang super excited about this
conversation we're gonna do a lot of
learning today
uh feature thank you so much for doing
this i'm happy to be here
i mean have you been anything that
starts with bang bang it's like it's
like
okay i'm ready all right so let's start
with your background you're doing
awesome work now but you've had a bunch
of cool things you've done in your past
so let's start there and then we can get
into
some of the bail reform stuff sure um so
i started in the labor movement i was um
an
organizer and really focused on how did
you improve the lives of low-wage
workers
and then ended up running um a labor
federation
um in addition we had a non-profit
policy organization that worked to
leverage the political power of the
labor movement
for moral policies so things like how do
you create living wage
for uh service sector workers how do you
have health care benefits for kids
regardless of documentation
and so spent 13 years really trying to
just figure out how did you improve the
lives of working people
and from there um was became really
interested in the kind of dichotomy
between
um the labor movement and the
environmental movement
and was struck by the fact that people
we often made choices in the labor
movement we were faced with like
good jobs or pollution like we didn't
have great choices
and so it just i wanted to understand
what would good choices look like could
you create an economy that was
sustainable for working people
and so i went and ran an organization
called green for all
and it had been founded by my friend van
jones who had gone on to the white house
and so i spent a couple of years doing
that work
um and learned a lot it was the last
non-profit i was in
um so i learned a lot about kind of what
worked and what didn't and then
ended up working in music i worked for
the musician prince after that
and then after i worked for prince i
became very interested in how
technology was impacting music and
especially artists of color
and what was uh fascinating to me is
that technology had not been a positive
force from my perspective in the labor
movement
specifically low-wage workers the kind
of who was court of the firm
changed and all of a sudden service
sector workers were making lower wages
they no longer were employees
and what i observed in music is that uh
basically the devaluing of content
um meant that kind of legacy artists or
artists of color the content was
worthless
and so i wanted to understand um what
worked and i didn't want to go back to
school so i went
um to work at a company called honor
and i went and ran um
i went there to run operations and then
ended up running
operations and revenue and i was there
for a couple of years
and enjoyed it a lot i learned a lot a
lot there
um and then decided to start my own
company because uh i learned a lot from
seth who is the ceo
um both raising money with him um i
i had this idea that uh raising money
was not complicated
and it was very uh and that uh
really that technology allowed you to
figure out like you could do anything
and i wanted our folks to have
technology
so i gotta ask the the working with
prince isn't exactly what most people
get to spend
part of their career doing what was that
like and kind of what did you do there
um so i uh acted as kind of uh i made
sure that his world work my first job
was to negotiate
uh with a lawyer to get his master's
back and i actually did it during my
maternity leave and so i didn't intend
to work for him
um van was like oh phaedra can do
anything and so we did that and then we
got his master's back and he just
basically was like you shall never leave
um and so then i ended up working for
him very oddly
um i think that's really interesting um
one i
um i didn't know a lot about music and
um and so i learned a lot about music i
learned a lot
um from him about um
really what it takes i think to be
excellent
and he practiced every day even though
as an amazing musician as he was he
practiced every day and that for me was
very impressive
um and i learned a lot about just
commitment to art and i think he's
probably the most
radical political person i know and so
also just watching how he used
music for leverage in the public space
so i just learned a lot
um and my favorite part about music is i
felt like people were much more honest
i had a meeting with a president of
record company and he said
we want to talk about exploitation and
how to exploit your music
and i was like this is the most honest
discussion like they call
using something exploitation in music
and so i was like oh like
this i can deal with you want to exploit
the music got it okay
check like i liked that level of
transparency that it's like
we just want to exploit you so there's
no pretense like let's be friends it's
like
we're gonna exploit your music so i was
like this is the cleanest terms i've
ever learned and used
so obviously he was brilliant and
amazing
and i learned a lot um and also made
some
uh just learned a lot about the way the
world worked the world
would be a much better place if radical
honesty like that was used everywhere
right like we're gonna exploit it i was
like wait okay that's okay cool like got
it
we've established the norm for how we
talk about things which i thought
that was the most transparent
communication i've seen in a long time
yeah i um i don't know very little about
the music industry but i recently
watched uh there's a two-part
documentary on netflix uh about garth
brooks
and they go through a lot of the early
days and kind of all of the nuances
around
you know the songwriter and who has
rights and then who chooses to perform
the songs and how the money gets uh
divvied up from
uh concerts and all stuff and you
realize very quickly like this is one a
massive business
but two is uh the longevity uh in terms
of revenue for a lot of these artists
um it sounds like things like the you
know the masters is super important over
long periods of time
and most people are young and they do
get exploited right and they kind of
just get taken advantage of and
end up not being a good spot yeah i know
it's funny we would see people they'd be
like oh my gosh i got a million dollar
deal and you'd say like oh that sounds
so great
but then you would realize is they got a
three album deal that they had to sell x
amount and they got a ten thousand
dollar advance
and it wasn't actually as great as they
thought so that was one thing i learned
a lot about
i don't know if uh if you've ever heard
bill burr the comedian talk about
hollywood accounting
is a is a term that he uses and he
basically says hollywood accounting is
something like we do a deal
you get sixty percent of uh profits i
get forty
percent but then there's a bunch of
clauses in there that say that i pay for
everything uh
so it's not really profits it's actually
a revenue split but after
i pay for everything and so it ends up
being more like 90 10 rather than the 60
40 i thought i was getting
because that yeah yeah it's definitely
hollywood accounting
and so how do you go from that you go to
honor right you learn a ton there
that's actually uh reuben harris uh
worked with you there and who uh so
kindly introduced us
but then how do you start to understand
um
a lot of the criminal justice reform
issues and bail reform
uh i'm lucky that van jones who
uh was a friend uh and a woman named
diana frappier who i started
promise with we'd all worked together in
different ways for about 12 years
diana and van founded the ella baker
center
and it was focused on criminal justice
reform and so
and then um became very interested
in it um really related to
the my observations around kind of what
was happening and i think
it's one of those things where if you
don't we all i think have people we love
who've been impacted by the criminal
justice system
and what i was um struck by is just the
numbers and so the fact like that
two-thirds of the people that were
incarcerated were there um
in jails like mostly county jails were
there and that they hadn't been
convicted of the crime that they were
arrested for
i think you know like you feel like your
family i always say like when it's your
family member you're like this is
someone who's dealing with addiction or
mental health issues and you see it
but oftentimes people don't see it for
other people's family members
and i think when i saw the statistics
and i start to felt them in my own life
in my own personal family's experience
i just was like this is it's such a
corrupt broken system
and um and the more i'm in it the more
corrupt i believe it is
um and um and so it's just been
so i just became interested just based
on the statistics of what and who was
happening
and um and that just became very
interesting to me
and then working in it and realizing
that if you are poor black or brown the
system is just designed to incarcerate
you
and it works hard i mean the fact that
people are in jail for parking tickets
like to me that is just it is only
because you are poor okay so i really
want to kind of drill into this because
this is the
to me the meat of the issue is most
people
some of the things you just said they
don't even know exist right so simple
things
some of the data i've seen you share
before is uh 2 million prisoners are
non-violent
and awaiting trial 70 of people in
county jails
have not yet been convicted of a crime
there are
example after example after example all
across the country where people
do uh things that you and i would think
of as fairly
petty uh really rule breaking i don't
even think of you know a parking ticket
as a crime necessarily right
but they end up right yeah and and they
end up basically
uh in jail so let's start just with
how do we get from uh something that is
uh not considered a violent crime or
something that is you know quote unquote
serious
how do we end up putting people in jail
like how do they get there versus
somebody who
gets a parking ticket they pay it and
you know they could never even imagine
going to jail for something like that
yeah i mean i think one is you start
with over policing right
which is who's most likely to get a
ticket right and the reality is
the poorer the blacker the browner the
neighborhood the more likely you are to
get a ticket in it
the more likely you are i mean i i did
uh something with an organization called
defy which is where you go volunteer
in a prison and then it's mostly tech
folks and it was so interesting because
for all these tech folks uh folks who
were in jail and i said i'm in jail for
seven years i did this and all the
textbooks like i did that i did that
and um and so just the stark reality
that
someone in america experiences the exact
same thing does the exact same thing and
they there are no consequences because
they have the resources to stop the
consequences so
one is just starts with the over
policing and so the likelihood that
you're more likely to get a ticker the
more likelihood you're
more likely to be arrested um and then i
think
uh the way it works we've seen it is you
might get a parking ticket
and this uh in some states it doesn't
work like this in some states you can't
go to jail for having a parking ticket
which is great
um you might get a parking ticket and
then usually what happens is that you
can't afford to pay it
and so either the fee increases or the
consequence happens so it might be you
lose your driver's license
and then you're driving on a driver's
license and you get arrested for a
suspended driver's license
and so one thing is we were sitting in
michigan and we were talking with some
um
folks about our software and we were
looking at who are the people most
likely to not show up for court
and what we saw is it was people who
were driving on suspended driver's
licenses
and so you thought they were we were
talking about what they were saying oh
bail should probably be high
and the idea that it's mostly working
people who have kids who have jobs
who are trying to drive their kids to
school and that those folks are the
people that pay the consequences or face
jail because they're broke
it is is not i think what the system is
designed to do and i think you're seeing
a lot of that
right now where people are saying look
the the police are not acting in a way
that's consistent with
trying to uphold law it's more about
kind of the oppression of some versus
the oppression of others and
um and so that's it so you you end up in
in jail basically you can't pay
something the consequences increase
and we look at it like we uh just
started a new software and the reason we
did is because we found payments were
really difficult
and so we launched a second software a
second product called promise pay
and the reason is is because we were
looking at parking tickets how do people
end up in trouble
and we looked at one city and we said
how could i like if i want to put myself
on a payment plan
and the requirement was you have to owe
over like 500
so you have to wait until it's so
expensive then you have to pay
50 up front then you have to bring your
tax returns to prove that you
deserve to put yourself on a pain plan
and you have to go down to this office
downtown
during the work week like it's just the
system isn't designed to make someone
successful and so
part of we thought about is how do you
build kind of products that actually
are designed for people to succeed could
you imagine if i called my cable bill
and i said
i can't pay it and they said well bring
your tax returns come down you
pay half up front like it's not it's not
reasonable
yeah and it feels like um some of this
is uh
intentional and then some of it is just
frankly uh you've got bureaucratic
organizations that have no clue the
realities on the ground right so
something as simple as
uh you know a quote-unquote good
intention rule is hey bring your tax
plan we'd love to get you under payment
plan
sounds like we're helping people but for
all the reasons you're explaining
actually end up causing more and more of
a problem right
yeah you know it's weird until i was in
the system i thought it was just like
racism or other folks when you're in it
you realize the system is actually
designed that way and the more i'm in it
the more i
see it i joke that being in the system
i've become a conspiracy theorist
and um and for me it was made clear when
someone said to me
i said oh this product will work this
way it'll be great and the person who
runs the system
said oh that's this is a difference i
don't care about people in the system
and i was like that level of clarity of
just
we don't care about people in the system
um
was was very important for me to
understand i remember someone saying
about a prison system that we talked to
and they said you know we wouldn't let
our dogs be in this prison
and so the idea that the people who
might be operating a system
don't think that dog their own dog
should be in that system or have no
care um speaks to how the system works
and you know so i think i've definitely
become more i think the system is
working the way it was designed to work
so explain that a little bit more when
you say design this way do you mean
um designed to imprison people and this
is more of like the private prison type
uh you know issues or is this uh more of
just
putting as many obstacles in place as
possible uh
and then therefore that either leads to
more revenue for the government and
possibly
jail time or kind of just clarify that a
little bit
um to me i think there's a
dehumanization of black and brown people
and and poor people and then i think it
there is
just the reality of the consequences
um like uh no system that
punishes people for not having money is
when it's government it's one thing
right if i get a product
and i'm doing something and then i don't
pay for it that's very different than
the assumption that you're going to pay
for something that the government
provides or that the consequences like
i realized where i live they have they
turn you into collections for library
fees
and um which is you know not does it
make any sense
uh to me so i i think the system just
works in the way and that it
criminalizes um things like poverty
it criminalizes and the consequences are
very different if you have good
representation as an example
um one of uh what's been great about our
work is we have people volunteer to help
us
and we have had a number of people who
have had um issues with the sec
try to come to us and say hey we get
this system stinks and how it's awful
and when you have good representation
you face you the consequences are very
different
than someone who has bad representation
and where we see it
is we see it in um someone let's say you
are waiting in court
you're well you have a you know you go
to court you have some type of thing
you've been charged with
then you end up waiting in jail because
remember you can't afford bail so you're
sitting in jail so then you take a plea
deal
and the plea deal has um no time
associated with it
but you can go back to jail with a
technical violation a technical
violation could be
you miss a meeting with your probation
officer you go
to what we saw an example someone got
married outside of the counties they
technically left the county
and so people end up in jail a lot for
technical violations
and often because due process goes away
with a technical violation so you don't
have a right to a trial in the same way
anymore
and so that's i think how the system
doesn't work is i can't afford to get
out so i take a plea deal that
might not make sense for me and then i
end up in trouble with a technical
violation that takes away due process
and so one of the things it sounds like
um is when you gave the example of you
can get on these payment plans but you
have to actually go down you've got to
bring tax
forms all that kind of stuff there's
almost like an education component to
this right if you know the rules
and you understand the correct path to
pursue
you may be able to deal with a system
that is already rigged against you
right and it sounds like that's what you
guys are doing at promises
you guys have kind of the muscle memory
you understand the system and you're
building products to try to
solve and make that easier for people to
interface with the system is that
accurate
yeah i think what we've discovered is we
want to work in places that people's
incentives are aligned so for example
what we like about payments is
no one wants to face the consequences of
not having money
and the government wants to get money as
quickly and easy as possible because
often when it does
is it sells its debt as distressed debt
to folks and gets 20 cents on the dollar
or it pays to track folks down
and then they face those consequences
and so we said look one thing that's
good is when those incentives are
aligned
because as a company we don't want to be
in a place where the incentives are to
incarcerate people you're like that's
the
part of kind of our value as a company
so where are those incentives alone so
then what we think about is
things like payments is how do you make
it as easy as possible one there's
already programs that peep that exist
so people should know you can qualify
for something and not have to figure out
how to go somewhere and register and do
stuff and i think covid
presents a lot of opportunities for us
because all of a sudden people can't go
into offices
um and so so anyway so it allows someone
to the software we've
currently done is called promise pay you
can go on you can
self-identify and say this is my income
then you qualify for a program we put
you on a payment plan we do things like
subscriptions
because it doesn't make sense that every
month you have to remember we do
reminders by text
use cash app venmo and other ways not
the assumption is you're going to have
a check um or a credit card that is
secured
and so just trying to make it as easy as
possible for people to pay
got it and then i guess as part of this
uh there's all the work that you can do
to keep people from being incarcerated
right so this is
everything from help them pay to prevent
kind of the escalation of consequences
or
the fines get them better representation
all that at some point though
some portion of the population is going
to go to jail and so there's kind of two
components is the way i think about that
there's jail and there's prison right
and jail
is uh the 70 of people who have not even
been convicted yet
we need to figure out how do we get them
out of jail especially when they're
non-violent offenders all that kind of
stuff and so
um that's one piece the prison component
i don't want to spend a lot of time on
that i feel like i could record a whole
other episode on what happens once
somebody's actually convicted
but specifically around the jail uh and
bail i think that's probably the one
thing that as i learned more and more
about it
was the most shocking to me was this
whole idea that literally
because you do not have enough money you
now have to go sit in jail whereas
if you had as little as 500 bucks right
all the way up to a couple of thousand
dollars
you could have your freedom and go and
make a living do whatever you want
while you're awaiting your trial so
maybe kind of just talk through
like how you've you know kind of
understood this and the problems you've
seen
specifically around that bail and the
issues there
yeah i mean the biggest issue that we
see around bail
is it's it's basically poor people uh
being in jail because they can't afford
to get out right the reality is
we're not assessing whether someone is
dangerous or not
because if i can pay a hundred dollars
it's not as though i'm less dangerous
because i can afford to pay
right and just as a reminder how bail
works is there's usually a schedule of
bail and it's based on usually what
you're charged with
which is usually determined by the cop
so a cop brings you in
and says hey i've arrested someone so
it's one person they can look at and say
okay
i'm arresting you for a dui a second
person they can arrest and say i'm
arresting you for excessive speed and
those all
have different consequences so one is
it's important no where does that
charging happen
right they're not formally charged
they've just been arrested and it's
based on the
decision of the arresting officer
usually for bail at least
so then there's a bail schedule and that
determines the specific thing so you
already are now kind of in a system
where we know racism exists and we're
stuck based on whatever the cop thinks
is what's appropriate
then you get to the system and then you
have a bail schedule so based on what
you're arrested for that you can pay
and usually there's a bail agency that
is like you pay 10
and um and sometimes people don't have
that 10 so if you don't have the 10
you stay in jail and um and so that
system for us is very broken and i will
say one thing i think to your point
about
i think we use this language of also um
folks who are not violent but it's
important to know what is violence look
like in the criminal justice system
so when we first started working we're
like oh we're going to work with
non-violent offenders and then we um one
of our clients
um walked us through we said okay i said
like what's the most violent offense
just so i can understand most likely to
happen
and it was people stealing cell phones
and
it's a violent offense if i take it off
a person it's not
and they feel threatened it's not if i
take it off of
a stand so i was like no one's telling
this is where kids don't know like
and it's mostly people that are young
under 21 that get arrested for it so all
of a sudden you have a violent
uh like so when we think about who we
work with that's that's who
a violent criminal might be according to
what your arrest is and so that's why i
think it's important for us to make the
case
that the idea that you're innocent until
proven guilty and really bail should be
um a way for folks to determine like
it's supposed to be risk level instead
of what it is right now which is
finances
yeah and my understanding and you are by
far
an expert compared to me is around these
bail bondsmen right is there's a lot of
kind of
i'll call it malicious nefarious
activity where
they literally as close to the county
jail as they can get
they've got their number plastered
everywhere i've literally seen bail
bondsmen's in colleges that are like you
know if you get arrested with our shirt
on and use it in the
uh you know in basically the the photo
you get 10
off like all kinds of crazy crazy stuff
uh
they actually are helping or are they uh
kind of making the situation worse
because the terms of the bail
that they help with is so bad i think
one thing to remember
for folks who don't know is that bail is
basically a surety or an insurance
business
so what happens is if i'm a local bail
bonds person
i'm probably paying an insurance uh
product one to three percent
but most of actually bail bonds are done
by a couple of big insurance companies
and there might be a local franchise and
so i think what's
what's bad about it is one it's the best
financial product for those insurance
providers
because very few people don't show up
for court and if they do you
the court has to make sure that you pay
something so one is someone's paying a
lot of stuffs like we talked to a
startup
where they think we could charge one to
three percent easily and make money so
one is
there's a lot of profit driven in there
and i think it's not awful like
from my perspective it's not as if
people should make profit the idea is
when the consequences are severe
and it's the poorest folks that are
paying the most that system is broken
and so i think what's broken is you have
a system that's built on people's
poverty and pain
and i don't think that's how we should
build systems and so
um and you are often paying a higher
bail amount because you don't have a lot
of like you don't have a house you don't
have something else so it's like
it's just a self-perpetuating system so
you look at like
should people pay bail if they're
innocent and we know many people are
likely to not be charged
and then it's like should the system be
determined by how much you can pay
so the problems are uh pretty obvious
once you start looking and learning
right and i think that you've obviously
spent a lot of time doing that
at some point you decided i want to go
solve some of this
maybe talk me through just like what was
the impetus for actually starting a
company building software and then what
do you think
those solutions look like both what
you've built already and then kind of
where you
you think opportunity exists for you
guys moving forward yeah
um and i would say um i think the
question is still out right because part
of what we're trying to understand
is can capitalism not be extractive and
i don't know right i think we're
building good products we have clients
but i think there's a question of scale
right and so what i wanted to do is i
wanted to start a venture company
and the reason is because i thought
scale was important i didn't want to be
like a non-profit and there's amazing
non-profits but for my models
we would help like 10 people 1000 people
and i wanted to think about how did you
help large groups of people so i wanted
to think about
what could you do that had large scale
and then i wanted to understand how
could you use technology for good
which is could technology be designed by
people who are thinking about solving
problems
for poor black and brown people would it
would you come with different solutions
um because oftentimes technology was
harmful
um and so so i wanted to understand that
and so then we just looked at what are
the spaces and places
that that provided the most opportunity
and i think the criminal justice system
was it
now sometimes i wish we hadn't shown the
chosen criminal justice system because
it's such a mess
and and there's so many um
more like questions of morality that
there normally isn't because like should
you make any money in the criminal
justice system should you
and the system is so flawed um so we
just thought
i was like i wanted to be able to know
that we built technology
with people i thought who needed it the
most with the ability to grow with the
most
impact and so that was what i looked for
and
and i thought it was very rare we knew
we raised 12 million
in our basically seed round and i knew
that was unusual for someone who wanted
to do
good and to raise capital from
traditional venture capital investors
so i got to ask how the hell did you
raise 12 million dollars for a seed
round
well we one is we did it like we did one
uh
we were we raised money before we had a
product or team and
and then raised like three months maybe
later the second like we raised it like
four and then i think seven point
something
um uh i because i ran revenue
and a lot of our investors were
investors in the company that i ran
revenue
i think that people said oh you get how
to make money
you get how systems work i mean that's
what i've discovered
is that it's it is in some ways is
pattern recognition which is they go oh
you ran revenue from zero to one of a
company that's making money
and that has large systems you should be
able to do that again
and so that's one thing so i think
because i ran revenue and
i think people invested and a lot of our
investors were investors in honor
um and then i think the problem is big
enough and mostly
the software is on the policing side so
i think people are like there's a market
that no one has conquered yet
and then i think we had investors who
felt like if
if there were a solution that we would
that they had um
i think a lot of our investors are very
wealthy and
felt like that this was an important
problem for the world to solve
um one of our investors was like you
should raise 40 million b
also because the problems are so big
that there's a question can you even
figure it out with 12 million right
and um and i was and i and i didn't
think it made sense to raise that much
but i think
there's a real question of like when
you're working with systems this big how
much do you need
and what was the first product that you
guys built at promise
yeah the first product we built was a
way for people to be able to
um provide support to people who were
getting
out of jail without bail and so it's
often what's called pre-trial software
and originally we thought we would be
able to work with people who did like
electronic monitoring or other things
and then we just discovered some of
those businesses were so
horrific that you could not work with
them so uh the way that you should think
about it is almost like a virtual
assistant
for someone so we give them reminders
about when their court dates are
we let them they make sure they have an
ability to communicate we
can do virtual meetings instead of
having to go in you can upload a photo
like whatever you need
so you don't have to go in the goal is
to keep someone in their home
and is that reliant on um maybe like
i'll call it government buy-in like do
you have to integrate with the
government systems on a county or state
level
yes yes so we do have to integrate with
their systems
and um something like when we first
started we had to integrate with
filemaker pro
a government was using filemaker pro and
so um
it's you know people where people are is
very different levels of technology and
software
um and um but i would say i think that
product requires that someone wants to
get people out of jail and i don't think
there's
a venture market of people who want to
get people out of jail in the system i
think
the reason we did the payments uh
software is because i think we could do
something where incentives aligned
i don't think our incentives are aligned
and part of why we've been very
purposeful about where we sell
is because i think even good software in
the hands of not great people
can end up being harmful i i tend to
agree with you so i think you're on to
something there
and then how do you think about um that
question of like
making money not making money around
criminal justice obviously you're
running a for-profit business that's got
equity investors
so at some point you've got to you know
figure that out what's the
kind of the current thought process or
iteration yeah i mean
the reason i thought we should be a
for-profit instead of a non-profit
is um one i was i have i have not seen
uh many nonprofits scale and so the
thing i was most interested in is scale
and um the other thing that i was
interested in is i think that capital
that government often aligns with
capital more than it does
like righteous morals and so one thing i
was like is could you
drive government behavior better by
being a for-profit or a non-profit
and i think i still believe it's more
likely to adapt to a for-profit
and um so i thought you know what's the
the best institution how to use it and
um and also the skill set like if
someone i
i went to cal state northridge right i
didn't go to harvard i didn't go to
stanford
and i think i i'm grateful for my
education but i also
i don't know that i was trained to work
in this environment and i wanted to
understand how did you hire people
based on a specific mission that were
trained to work in an environment
so like i love a street hustler that's
my favorite person to work with which is
how i identify
but i also knew i needed people who had
an mba and understood systems and i
think
i've been able to attract those people
much better in a for-profit world than i
was in a nonprofit world
and so for me it was how do i have the
greatest impact and i think that
staffing resources
and um vehicle and that felt better in a
for-profit
and i wish there was a way to to do that
in a non-profit
you know i i don't know what i do i
think it's also what i don't like
is the assumption also that like people
who want change should be broke
and people who don't want the idea that
it's like
we should tell all these people who want
better systems for their family
you should be truthful in like and your
truth is living in poverty instead of
your truth is like
building generational wealth where you
can take care of your family and take
care of yourself like i just
i think the idea that goodness is
determined by poverty is just the
like i feel like that's a bag of goods
we sell to like people who are already
poor
and to tell them there's honor in it
well it's usually the rich people
peddling that uh that story for sure
you're honorable yeah
let me keep the money you keep the honor
right
i got it um so you've been at this for a
while now
and uh and you spent a lot of time
really understanding the the nuances of
a lot of the issues
i'm gonna ask you two questions one what
is the thing you've been most surprised
by
and then what is the one thing that
you've been the least surprised by that
you've learned
i think i've been most surprised by
um how structured the system is to
incarcerate people
that it's just you know like you hear
the intellectual stuff
like where it's like oh bail reform and
all these things and i thought we were
going to go
and the gates were going to open up and
we would say look we figured out a way
so poor people don't be incarcerated
and everyone could say oh i get it the
statistics show here's why you go to
jail we're going to automatically
correct the system and when people were
just
very transparent like we want to keep
those people in jail that was surprising
to me
because it felt like only something i
would have anticipated in a character
on a like movie right like it was just
like so blatant
that that was very surprising to me um
what i have been
least surprised by um is
uh yeah
i've been least surprised by um
the technology that exists
that it is exactly what i thought it
would be
and um and i think yeah i'm at least
like
i mean it's not it was not surprising to
me that we run into filemaker pro and
microsoft access all the time
yeah it's pretty crazy and then i guess
the last piece here
is as you think about the people that
you are
helping right those that are kind of
being screwed over by the system
how much is there uh around an obstacle
of like
they just don't know how to use
technology they don't have a desire to
use technology
or is it something where if you give
them the tools
they are able to use this and you don't
have to worry so much about like
what i always talk about like the human
technology interface
right if you give a 90 year old woman
a great piece of technology if she just
doesn't have the desire to ever pick it
up it doesn't matter
right same thing here is there's a lot
of things where i see people
uh when they're given the tools they run
with it and they're highly successful do
you find that is the case or do you see
much more around where you guys are
having to educate on
here's how the technology works here's
why it's important that you continue to
use it and really even build that into
the product maybe
yeah i think one is we do a lot of work
about
you know about design like thinking
about how the product is used and
and we learned very quickly that
training was a very important part of
what we did
like you couldn't just sell software and
say good luck see you later
you had to like spend a lot of time on
training um
so you definitely do but i think part of
it i get is there
i we haven't run into a number of
amazing products
so i get why if i'm a government
employee why i'm not impressed or
inclined to go follow this
because i haven't seen impressive
results like if i'm using trying to
adapt filemaker pro
to manage thousands of people in the
criminal justice system like you think i
want your new software to help
connect to my filemaker pro that i can't
use on my cell phone like it's like
you know um so so so one i get i think
on that side
what we find is people um the thing i
find consistently is
is most i've not run into anyone who
wanted to go to jail
and so when you give them a tool to stay
out of it it is not shocking that they
use it it is what's been interesting is
people started coming to us because they
said your collection rate is so high
and uh so uh uh authorities
of uh an agency came to us and said hey
we want you to do collections
and i said it's really not brain surgery
which is if you make a system easy
for people to pay and assume they want
to pay they actually
pay it is like but if you think about
government systems like paying your
taxes like
i gotta go i gotta sign in i gotta have
this specific credit card i gotta pay a
fee to use it i got to find somewhere it
dies you know like it's just good
technology
it is shocking that uh that one of the
breakthroughs is literally
hey if they don't pay they're going to
go to jail so if you make it easier to
pay they'll actually pay you
like that is that that to me is the
biggest takeaway from our conversation
so far
of like just how absurd the other side
of this looks at it
right because if we assume that people
don't want to go to jail
then you assume they don't pay because
they don't have the ability to
or they don't pay because it's not easy
to pay and when you correct for that
people perform better it is not shocking
i mean
if i said to you netflix or any other
service the way we're going to run
payments is you got to come down to an
office
you got to prove you need the service
you gotta pay to park you gotta wait
and then and if you don't pay then you
gotta come back and you gotta pay cash
during specific hours it's like who
would collect money that way
nobody what about uh on the uh what i'll
call kind of customer acquisition
channels like where do you guys see the
the channels that work for you um the
channels that work best for us one is
because government is usually our client
people like we get a phone number we can
just reach out to you which is much
different
um and what's great for us about
government is usually
most of our business comes from
government agencies recommending us to
another government agency
by and large we don't have a sales team
right now we have like
it is almost always we just hired our
first sales person
and but otherwise all our growth has
been from person to person
that's awesome i love that uh before i
wrap up i asked the same two questions
to everybody and then you're going to
get to ask me one question to finish
the first is a little bit more serious
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
what a great question the most important
book i've ever read
um i feel like maya angelou i know why
the caged birds sing
and i think because it gave me a vision
of what my life could be and just in a
boldness
that i saw that i hadn't seen before
i loved that i i received something on
the podcast who was talking all about
exposure being one of the most powerful
things in the world just exposing people
to ideas and what's possible
can really kind of drive that sounds
like that book did that for you
absolutely all right a fun one aliens
believer or non-believer oh total
believer
why because i know that you don't know
everything the government's doing
almost everybody says they believe but
nobody has used that as the reason why
that is amazing you think that there's a
high probability that there has been
contact
total no question i mean how arrogant
for us to think we're the only life
that's usually the the logic that most
people use right is like
hey the world's big place but uh but
saying that we don't know what the
government's doing is pretty good up
that might be up
there yeah like who knows what
one question do you have for me to
finish up how could you be helpful to me
and uh that's what i want to know oh
uh two things um
there's a lot of very well connected
people that come on the podcast
uh and many of them are incredibly
receptive
to uh generally being good humans and
as i told you before the podcast started
uh things like bail reform criminal
justice reform
i think they uh intellectually
understand um
this is a problem solutions can be
created
uh i think a lot of them actually are in
a position of like i don't know what to
do
so like like that that's kind of a piece
that you probably would have a great
conversation with
uh and then the second is uh you tell me
whenever you want to come on and talk
about uh
issues and uh and we can absolutely do
it there's
probably more people than uh that i ever
thought would listen to this
and uh so you can use this as your
microphone whenever you want
great okay perfect do people not ask
that i'm like okay how can you help me
grow my company
people are too scared you know you know
what you just did is you hit me with the
uh
the music industry hey look we're going
to exploit this right
how can you i'm trying to grow a company
how can you help me grow my company
look it's um who is that i think it's
mark sustra from uh
upfront ventures one time wrote a uh a
blog post and he basically said
you don't get if you don't ask right
which which is uh i don't know why
necessarily people need to read a whole
blog post about it but he did a great
job laying it out and really explained
to people like hey if you don't ask
people for help you're not gonna get
help
totally okay cool i love it
all right you let me know when you're
gonna come back on and we'll talk about
a couple other things afterwards okay
thanks so much